hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
outlast 2 is about to be released upon
the world but I'm a little worried that
people may miss out on this one due to
limited information and basically a lack
of attention either way still will be
inundated by grown men and women
screaming like three-year-olds all over
twitch in YouTube and I may even do it
myself if you're new to the series
horror in general or you're a trend but
us here are 14 things you should know
about outlast 2 okay let's do this
outlast 2 puts you in the shoes of Blake
Langerman a cameraman working with his
wife Lynn these two are investigative
journalists who don't mind almost dying
to get the scoop on a story you are
following the murder of a Jane Doe and
if you haven't watched CSI in the last
10 years a Jane Doe is a woman who
cannot be identified the male version
would be a John Doe anywhere our dead
Jane Doe was pregnant and after
following Clues you find yourself in the
Arizona desert trying to piece together
her story the camera in your hand holds
the key mechanic to the whole game
series as it's night vision mode is your
only way to see in the dark and to make
matters worse your battery is low so you
must use it clicking lis or locate new
batteries constantly this really feeds
into the fear of being decisive and
getting things done or just sitting in a
locker all day I did the latter speaking
of hiding in the original outlast which
was set in a psychiatric Asylum you were
boxed in and only really had two options
for hiding either under a bed or in a
locker this has definitely grown in
outlast 2 which now uses open gameplay
and although this is most definitely a
linear game it has larger areas to
maneuver through for example take the
cornfield seen in the demo which I
assumed the plantlife would add like a
brick wall hell no you can run in the
field and hide from your pursuers I also
hid underwater until I needed a breath -
this game has tried to innovate on the
original and I salut
for that I'm the look behind mechanic
which was in outlast one has been
refined and it's bloody brilliant now
peering over your shoulder whilst
running from a knife wielding madman
will definitely make your heart skip a
beat if you are quickly offended
I would think enough now and avoid
hourglass two altogether as the
advertising for this game has been ultra
edgy I'm sure you've already seen the
inverted crosses on fire of course used
in the trailer or the room full of dead
babies in the demo complain our dead
babies I'm jumping on dead babies jump
over baby ghosts crush or even the witch
that does them unspeakable things beyond
junk this game is created to make you
feel on edge and is definitely not made
for the people with a nervous
disposition ah oh and if you have a
pacemaker definitely steer clear of this
way
class two is based on real events if
that doesn't make you shudder I'll make
your backside tense a little well listen
to this back in 1978 a town in Guyana
which was referred to as John's town was
the place where nine hundred and
eighteen people lost their lives cult
leader Jim Jones performs a ritual best
mass suicide but some people still
believe it was a mass murder and not a
mass suicide
I couldn't research anymore after that
because I'm all alone at home and it's
pretty dark outside and I'm now really
scared of playing this game is now a
good time to admit I never finished the
first game well it's true I was so
terrified of that big bust and Chris
Walker that I had to check how the story
ended online even though outlast 2 has a
new story and new characters it is set
in the same universe as the first game
and The Whistleblower expansion 2 so
expect references to those titles to
prove I'm a manly man I'm going to go
back to outline and complete the story
and I'll upload a story synopsis for
those who haven't played the first
outlast title if you have PS plus or
games with gold you may already have the
original outlast Xbox users were gifted
it in January of this year I believe and
PS plus users had it all the way back in
February 2014
back when PS Plus was so much better
than games with Golden's or how times
have changed from if you downloaded the
game all those months and years ago then
play it now and prepare your mind and
body for the second installment
[Music]
if you never fled the originals but are
thinking about picking this one up then
you can pick up the Trinity Edition
which has outlast outlast whistleblower
and outlast 2 all together in one
perfect little sexy package
have you spent ridiculous amounts of
money on VR I spent 350 pounds on PSP
and really don't have anything to play
on it sadly there is no be a support for
this title to which I won't lie I'm
pretty happy about because I don't
really want to relive the horror that I
suffered in Resident Evil 7 it left skid
marks on my underwear it's likely this
will change in the future but at present
you'll have to settle through your
oversized television
speaking of filling your punch did you
ever see the Kickstarter campaign
created by red barrels the deadly kind
outline the under scares adult diaper or
nappy if you're a fellow for it were
designed by leading scientists to help
you against the sudden anal seepage that
fear can cause if you haven't seen the
Kickstarter video it's definitely worth
your time and sadly we'll never see the
real thing as they fail to reach their
goal I thought this kind of viral
advertising was a great idea
would you buy a pair and there's even a
limited edition with a wearable mark
Knight and Huntsman if you're a console
gamer the thoughts of mid generation
upgrades are a tricky thing to fathom
but PC game is you know the drill
already if you have a ps4 Pro you can
use the pro mode to enhance the game's
visuals and framerate stability to you
PC guys don't need to know that right
answer those of you who are thinking
about picking up a project Scorpio
amazing well I'd expect similar upgraded
visuals to bring that a couple of things
worth mentioning before we end this
horror fest expect about 10 hours of
gameplay on your first classroom so
approximately the same as resonable 7
I'm expecting speedrunners to finish
this game in about 90 minutes maybe even
an hour how do you flow the outlast 2
demo and did you see the little Freddy
Krueger Easter Egg
well he's watching you from the shadows
in the first 5 minutes of the game and
if you don't know who he is he's
basically a serial killer who murders
you when you're asleep yes he finds you
in your dreams just ask Johnny Depp I
wonder if this is a clue to the story
[Music]
finally the original teaser trailer for
outlast who had a strange people given
running throughout all y'all
well I'm sure you've already figured out
if you play it backwards you may get
something different and you get children
you lovers of God ring snake defenders
of his peridot all I use is suffering
together now in the employ of day okay
hey you are in a corrupt and healthy
part of the Romans in applied in civil
as a 4th month and 22nd day of the
sixteenth year on the third millennium
all reckoning the spider our lab way to
college great oh if is world ready
[Music]
what a good girl no bloody and we lovely
[Music]
show no mercy just to confirm the game
is really compared for Xbox one and PC
on the 25th of April
are you picking it up I will definitely
be grabbing this one but I don't expect
to finish it anytime soon
I mean egos at all dice's I'm out of
regression related if this was worth
your time chuckle I can think about
subscribing if you haven't already I'll
see you next time